godzilla singular point is out in
netflix and this series is a new take on
the king of the monsters and
his role in the world it brings a new
origin story to the kaiju and brand new
designs
some designs that are way more radical
than others
in it we see three types of rodan four
forms of godzilla
anguirus a swarm of humongous a school
of mandus
a new kaiju from india called salunga
and even small mods that came out
in a big swamp maybe they were a version
of mothra
but the best part was in the end credit
scenes of the final episode of the
series
and in it we see mechagodzilla so before
we go deeper into the video subscribe
to be a part of the mind cue family and
now let's discuss this mecca
now let's start first with the godzilla
skeleton found
hidden underground okay so godzilla is a
singular point
and is in control of the red dust
archetype while godzilla can be killed
and die from other factors he will
always manifest himself again
and after his death with improved
control over the red does as he comes to
understand our reality better
however it is not known how long the
revival process
takes and his last incarnation dies 50
years prior to the
events of the series before re-emerging
as another
form called accordless and it just goes
on evolving into the ultimate form
in all four of his forms godzilla expels
a large amount of archetype from his
skin
in the form of a red miss the skeleton
of the previous godzilla seems to show
the same ability of producing the red
mist
and although it's dead it still
resonates a frequency that is translated
into a song
so the question of mecha godzilla why is
it being created
why is mechagodzilla being constructed
by humans in the end credit scenes of
the final episode
well since godzilla and the other kaiju
came up abruptly and humans with their
weapons
had little to no effect on killing the
kaiju this would have created a
desperation among our species
and just as in the most verse a secret
organization would take
it on itself to create a doppelganger of
the kaiju in order to
fight it the next time it comes back
since by then they would know that
godzilla wasn't just a single phenomenon
because
the skeleton was evidence of a past
event and if there were two
that came up then why not a third gojira
mechagodzilla would be
humanity's answer to this thread from
another dimension
from the world of the archetype and the
singular points so now let's see the
design of this mecca
and what would it be like while under
construction and far from being
completed the mecca seems to be very
much
resembling the robot from the showa era
with visible elements of godzilla
skeleton still apparent
the robot would have the same posture of
godzilla ultima
which is kind of like a hunch dinosaur
as it was created over the skeleton of
the previous one that died
and of course it would have to be a
little bit bigger and taller than ultima
with the addition of metal parts
on top and below the feet so let's start
with the limbs as they appear first on
the end credit scenes
as blueprints of the construction work
the metalwork on the hands and feet of
mechagodzilla seems to be well
integrated with the skeleton
as the joints of each part being
implanted with artificial red parts that
would allow for controlled movement the
claws of the limbs looks to be outside
the metal superstructure but they
are still addition to the moving parts
most notably
there are weapon systems that appear to
be either large caliber guns
or face beam weapons since godzilla that
appeared
and the series was invulnerable to
conventional weaponry so a new type of
weapon
then we get to the upper part of the
body the neck and the head and by the
looks of it the metal superstructure
would be very similar to the showa era
mecha godzilla
the dorsal plates are embedded in the
exoskeleton with power cells being
stored in them
the eyes and nose looks to have weapons
integrated to them
just like the showa mecca's and the
central computing system and the power
units are both embedded inside the skull
which houses the brain
and the mouth houses a beam weapon that
can be shot like an
atomic breath which would mimic the
atomic breath of the rail godzilla
the chest plates also possess two axes
giving the vibe of the original mecha
design
but the joints of the limbs give a curio
feel to them
so regarding the powers or the probable
paths that this mechagosa would possess
by looking at the blueprint design and
the robot under construction this mecha
would have eye beams and
maybe nose beams as well now the main
weapon would be the beam that is
installed inside the mouth
and this one would rival the power of
the atomic breath the hands and
feet to have large caliber guns that can
either shoot projectiles
or energy beams from them and obviously
there would be missiles as well
and if you look closely at the shoulder
of the mecca there are parts that allow
for shoulder-based heavy weaponry
to be installed in them just like those
of kiryu and the supermega godzilla
and that's about all we have on
mechagodzilla from singular points
and this one will most definitely be the
big baddie of the second season
so now we come to the end of the video
do like for support
subscribe to be a part of the minecube
family and most importantly hit that
bell button for regular updates
on new monster content right here on
minecube
till the next one take care fam